I felt that I was a monster incapable of
love you know love to me would have to
mean love for a man I am Nick Gillespie
with Reason TV and today we're talking
with Jonathan Roush who works at
Brookings Institution a great journalist
of many years who's also contributed to
reason and his most recent publication
is a great new e-book from the Atlantic
called denial my 25 years without a soul
you can find it at the Atlantic calm
slash denial John Roush thanks for
talking with us
it's good to see you again denial my 25
years with that [ __ ] is about your
it's a discussion it's an essay about
your coming to terms with being a
homosexual or being gay early on in the
book you talk about being an invert
which is kind of a variation I'm work
you've done event being an introvert
where you are kind of folded inward and
looking inwards and you suggest that
your sexuality made you which seem to be
at odds with everybody around you and
you weren't sure what it was or what it
meant and that it had you constantly
looking inward for answers about why you
seem to feel different and aloof could
you talk a little bit about the what you
mean when you talk about being inverted
and how that plays that in terms of
introversion or your kind of personality
so I would say inverted and introversion
although a nice alliteration totally
different okay an introvert is perfectly
healthy way to be it just means that you
instead of receiving energy from other
people you lose energy by socializing an
invert which is what I was is someone
who turns their entire world in their
entire personality upside down in a
heroic feat of denial of who they are
and it's an attempt to distinguish that
there's a state that is deeper and
stranger even than the closet you know
if you're a gay person in the closet you
probably know you're gay you may be
acting on that but you're pretending to
be straight maybe even with yourself if
you're an invert you have clear
objective evidence every day that you
are gay you know if you're a man the
plumbing tells you there's nothing else
right and you twist and deform your
whole psyche and tell yourself crazy
stories and you tell yourself that black
is white
in the top is bottom and Northeast South
in order to deny this obvious fact and
that's what I was you can talk about
your kind of you were living life as a
photographic negative yeah
it's everything is in proportion
everything else everything seems logical
and yet it's all completely backwards
and that's pretty much where your
soullessness came from right because you
were so inverted that you you couldn't
really afford an interior life yeah I
couldn't have an interior life I felt
that I was a monster incapable of love
you know love to me would have to mean
love for a man and that to me could not
be love that was some kind of strange
wacko psychosis I had so you know the
ability to love is the very center of
the soul for most people you know it
kind of defines our personality and
without that you're kind of you know I I
was hollowed out I was doing everything
else in life I was looking and acting
mostly normal but I went around with
this certain interior knowledge that I
alone among all of human beings had been
born without the capacity to love you
know one of the things that I think is
so memorable and touching about the book
and interesting is that it is you say
you're you you are not claiming that you
were a typical teenager that you were a
typical gay person whatever but there's
clearly an exemplary nature that reaches
beyond issues of sexuality to you know
yeah and Nick the biggest surprise to me
of this book ever since I first started
showing it to people you know I wrote it
for myself thinking I was describing
this kind of crazy pathology and wanted
to get it on paper before I lost touch
with it
it was receding disappearing like a
dream and when I showed it to people
especially straight people they said
again and again I lived through a
version of that and I would say how is
that possible you weren't gay you
couldn't have explained you know you
like girls with boobs right what would
the problem be and people again and
again say no there are aspects of my
personality I was
or with it I was turning upside down I'm
amazed by that talk about there's a
character of Paul your first great crush
that is the person who kind of awakened
sexual longing in you which you didn't
necessarily recognize immediately as
such talk about him and about how that
changed your ability to kind of you know
keep things in a homeostasis yeah you
know it's also typical yet it seems so
bizarre at the time so there I was you
know I started getting fascination with
you know athletic guys guys with muscles
from earliest memories so then I'm 13 or
14 and this guy Paul enters my life he's
just a classmate but I don't think in
the entire time I I knew him which was
many many years he ever said an unkind
word so the friendship was rewarding and
you know I was an introvert and you know
socially not the most adept and not good
at support so I needed friends the
friendship was very rewarding the other
side the the roaring raging the crazy
aunt in the basement who kept sending
these signals that all I wanted was to
see him with his shirt off and then in
his presence my knees would get weak and
my skin would get you know sweaty that
was not a blessing in any way that was I
spent so much energy for so many years
trying to bottle that into a place where
it wouldn't go but then you wrote as you
you know it took you a long time to kind
of come to terms with being gay why was
I so much more willing to believe I was
a monster than a homosexual and you say
it's partly because of naivete what did
what did what do you mean by that what
kind of naivete you know the real answer
to your question Nick is that I don't
know the answer to your question I posed
that as a question in a book and I say
maybe I was naive as an answer you know
maybe I just didn't understand about
homosexuality this is in the 70s and 80s
and in those days being gay in the 70s
meant that you were out at clubs doing
this is a stereotype but there was truth
to it and it's what filtered down to me
you know when you're crazy delivery
right and you're having doing nitrate
poppers your clubs all the time you're
having crazy wild sex but never a family
you're alienated from society I didn't
want that and then came AIDS and that
was that meant being gay was a death
sentence so I thought maybe it was you
know partly naive about what being gay
meant but the truth is to this day
having come out the other side of that
and seeing how all of these nightmares
about how terrible it would be to ever
admit what was going on how all of that
was a complete fabrication I still don't
understand why I and a lot of other
people would have this would rather
think of themselves as monsters in homo
section this is one of the places where
I think the book goes beyond just
talking about sexual orientation because
a lot of people are more willing to
think of themselves as monsters then as
a you know an example of a type in a way
but you write that in in the book it's
inexpressibly heartening to see today a
whole generation of homosexuals grow up
wondrously aloof from the disgust I took
for granted and I assume that's both
your own disgust as well as social
societal discuss it it's so it has
gotten better but it hasn't gotten fully
and go away you know people want to be
like other people they want to be normal
they want to have kids biological kids
with the person they love
and especially for I think boys there's
these elements of masculinity and a fear
of the feminine side and of what
homosexuality stands for and there's
worried about discrimination there's all
of that but for me the single best
biggest thing may be marriage it's where
the book begins I did not figure out I
was gay until I was 25 but somehow I
knew that I would never get married from
the age of 9 or 10 and that meant life
without family it meant no destination
for love it meant no permanent part
it meant kind of it looked at the time
like a nomadic emotional lifestyle and
providing marriage I think is
transformative not for everyone but but
that tells it's not just the people who
go out and get married right now who are
adults it's the kids who grow up with a
destination for their love thinking
about the first date and the first kiss
and the first crush as leading to a home
and a family and stability you yourself
a previous book you wrote about gay
marriage which if I recall the epigram
at the beginning of the book or epigraph
but you said Michael you're we're
writing to your long-term partner marry
me when we can which as I recall every
woman I know who read that said that is
the most romantic thing that I've ever
heard every man said that is the
cheapest bit of had act that you could
do because you you knew you could say
I'd marry you if I could but then I
can't
yeah but bring us up to date are you
married and we got married Michael and I
got married as soon as we could after
the District of Columbia legalized gay
marriage in 2010 and we're happily
married and it's better than I imagined
well we'll leave it there Jonathan Roush
is the author most recently of denial my
25 years without a soul it's available
at the Atlantic com slash denial John
thanks very much thank you